a star is born is directed by Bradley
Cooper and stars him and Lady gaga and
tells the story of a rock country style
singer who is nearing the end of his
career simply because he can't stop
drinking he's a severe alcoholic he's
very famous for what he's done but he
comes across Lady Gaga's character in a
bar one night and she's singing and he's
just completely taken away by what she's
doing
and he feels that she has considerable
talent and tries to get her involved
with his performances because for the
first time in a long time he's feeling
like himself again he's feeling like
rejuvenated creatively and emotionally
and for her this is like this great
break an opportunity and it starts a
whirlwind romance that goes in a lot of
deep places emotionally along with some
fantastic music I thought this film was
great I was very impressed with what
Bradley Cooper was able to put together
he's someone I've always been fascinated
with because for some people he's just
the funny guy from hangover and then in
other roles
he's just magnificent and he shows all
this depth and range if you ever watched
his interview on Inside the Actors
Studio you might cry because he's
sitting there being interviewed by James
Lipton and he can't keep it together
because it's just so emotional for him
that he's and at this point in his
career which I love and here he has
shown that he has considerable talent at
constructing a film and Lady Gaga who I
think is insanely talented and one of
the best musical voices of our current
times is incredible in the film she
obviously has a role here that's
tailor-made for her it's not like the
character herself is like Lady gaga
but it's obviously one that she could
play very well kind of like mm an
eight-mile she's never gonna get a role
this perfect for her but that being said
she really did knock it out of the park
her voice is just astoundingly great the
music is so good some of the best songs
I've heard in a film written for a film
in a long time and Bradley Cooper I
think gives the best performance I've
ever seen from him really touching stuff
really powerful movie that being said my
favorite actor in the film and I think
the best performance in the film is
actually
from Sam Elliot who I feel like is a
shoo-in for Best Supporting Actor I've
seen him in things for years I mean he's
incredible although I packed a Roadhouse
for God's sakes which is just a guilty
pleasure but um here he plays the
brother of Bradley Cooper's character
who helps him out on his tours gets gigs
for him and he's having a very hard time
watching his brother circle the drain
and it's some of the best acting I think
I've seen this year there's one scene in
a car no dialogue
he's just he puts the car in reverse and
he turns around it's just that shot
right there is a shoo-in for like all
the Best Supporting Actor Awards this
year and if he doesn't even get
nominated I would actually be upset the
chemistry to between Gaga and Cooper is
off the charts I mean these people feel
like they're in love this doesn't feel
like acting it feels like one of those
films where the cameras captured real
events and that's like the highest level
of praise for acting in regards to
issues there are some major majorly
important character moments that do feel
rushed there's one scene in particular
involving a ring at a dinner table and
it was just like what what there's other
moments where sometimes time has passed
but you don't really realize it and then
you realize the time has passed but it
didn't really feel like it past you know
the narrative isn't always perfectly
flowing there's little character beats
like that that could be a little more
fleshed out and some more emotion given
to them but the way you watch an artist
taken by the industry and turned into
something that she isn't and a man
another artist who's been in the
industry for a long time who feels like
he's running out of juice it's such a
great commentary on what the industry
the music industry can also do to an
artist transform them into like a
product like a package for everyone to
just consume rather than someone who has
something to say and it's actually a
really beautiful message so some of the
best music I've heard in a movie for a
long time some of the best performances
of the year Sam Elliott man he knocked
it out of the park Cooper is going to be
a great director if he can continue this
type of filmmaking and this type of
momentum and Lady Gaga does have a
serious future as an actress
I'm gonna give it an a-minus guys thank
you so much as always for watching look
forward to more reviews very soon and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
you
[Music]